[Music]
you ready for your big speech honey
fangs yes i think so but
ah
johnny is giving me the greatest
headache of my entire existence right
now like a giant wooden stake right
through my brain oh you know johnny he
just gets a little carried away yes
exactly and ruins everything that's the
problem well you're gonna have to get
used to things being done a little
differently around here when you retire
you retire
you retire
retire
not so loud maybe it's supersonic
heating why would she be listening don't
be so paranoid yes i i'm sure you're
right i just
i don't want anything else to go wrong
everything has to be perfect when i
finally give the hotel
to
[Music]
what and johnny yes and johnny oh it is
a big step i know how much this hotel
means to you
ah yes but it is time to let go
and start a new chapter together well
you are just all sorts of wonderful
aren't you well it's not for nothing
that they call me count wonderful oh
do they and also dark prince of lovely
news
lord of smoochie times
oh
[Music]
on january 14th family movie night is
getting revamped only on prime video
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now
but is this safe though let's find
[Music]
is out okay down here hey drac what's up
oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
you're human dread dad
oh no i have a total dad bod
um what is going on
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've literally
never seen you before
there is a place deep in the amazon only
there can the transformations be
reversed time to go
stereo man
if we don't fix you guys soon you'll be
like this forever
being a human is the worst
quito
hotel transylvania transfer mania
boy that was fun rated pg coming january
14th only on prime video
[Music]
bye